la journée internationale des écrivains
persécutés et emprisonnés existe depuis
1981 la maison de la poésie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines souhaite
mettre en avant ses auteurs contraint à
l'exil au silence à la prison ou même la
mort pour sensibiliser les jeunes un
écrivain et journaliste roumain forcé de
quitter son pays a rencontré aujourd'hui
les élèves du lycée emilie de breteuil à
montigny il est arrivé en france en 1987
comme réfugié politique auteur interdit
est censuré dans son pays d'origine
d'une manière le nord j'ai toujours
écrit au tout d abord de l'individu et
pour et le pouvoir ça m'a toujours
intéressée de penser de réfléchir à la
manière dont le pouvoir manipulent les
individus on oublie parfois qu il à une
époque où le seul espace de liberté
était la littérature il a des auteurs
qui sexy mais il ya des auteurs qui
résiste toujours sur place qui risque
aussi parfois la persécution mais encore
une fois pour résumer la littérature a
été toujours toujours
un espace de liberté et par son côté
subversive et la toujours dérangé le
pouvoir totalitaire